Reggie Miller our great buddy from NBA
and TNT Reggie will be on the call
Thursday night for heat at Hawks mclubbe
and hawk 7:00 p.m. Eastern with Kevin
Harlan Halloween night doubleheader
includes Nuggets at the pelicans 9:30
p.m. Eastern
Reggie before we get started the NBA
stuff you're in Los Angeles we remember
what happened with the fires there last
year they came right up basically
literally to your backdoor how is
everything where you are out there and
what you're dealing with
well we've relocated to Calabasas while
the Malibu house gets a love makeover as
you mentioned the flames came all the
way up and the smoke damage and the
patio and so we're we're in the process
of redoing some things there in Malibu
so we're over in Calabasas and it's real
here it's you know obviously we call it
fire season around here with the Santa
Ana winds two brave men and women first
responders have been unbelievable and
they get a little bit of break right now
because the winds aren't going but from
what I've been hearing tomorrow is
supposed to be the worst of all the days
in terms of gust of wind anywhere
between 50 to 70 miles an hour winds so
we we hear and feel your prayer so we
thank you guys but as of now so far so
good but we're you know everyone's
pulling for one another here to you know
find safe refuge somewhere and hole up
and you know we'll get through this
together that's good to hear Reggie as
you know we do wish you the best no easy
segue here but let's get right to it
week one in Los Angeles for both
basketball teams if you were a fan I'll
start with the Clippers after week one
do you feel better worse exactly like
you expected to be about this team
for the Clippers exactly what I thought
again no Paul George and they're still
three and one Kawhi Leonard is playing
at an MVP clip I knew their defense
would be good and they've shown that but
what's been impressive and what we saw
from the Clippers last season was that
unbelievable bench led by The Sixth Man
of the Year the three times six man of
the year Lou Williams and his running
mate montrezl Harold but now that they
that is like no Harkless
you know to the bunch juh michael green
they're long they're athletic and they
really get after you defensively so it's
not a big drop off from the starters to
the bench and for the Lakers you know
with all these teams that have added new
pieces like Houston adding Russell
Westbrook you know to add Anthony Davis
to play alongside LeBron James and a lot
of these new players I think it's going
to take some time I think Frank Vogel
has done a great job of playing Anthony
Davis a little bit more at that center
position I know he's not high on that
but when they play small with LeBron at
four and AD at five they are a beast in
the open court so when they go small and
they have Caruso at that smaller lineup
more three-point shooting and they're
more athletic red going back to the
Clippers for a second Patrick Beverley
is a guard but he's really more of a
defensive past a defensive stopper and
he's becoming kind of the Clippers
version of draymond Green may be the
version of Ron Artest said when he was
at his best where part of his job is to
frustrate the other team and the star
player how important is a role like that
to a championship team he's one of those
guys yeah I put him in the same breath
like Bill Laimbeer Dennis Rodman you
hated to play against those guys but you
wish they were on your team and he's an
agitator and he doesn't back down and he
knows his job is number one to play
defense pick up full disrupt the offense
and make an occasional wide-open three
which he's been getting a lot of thank
Mike could you imagine Reggie fewer in
your heyday he would be on you
specifically on and off the ball well
I'll tell you he's too
to guard me I would have put him right
down there in the post and just shot
overall but I I get where the saw last
year him guarding Kevin Durant he
started this year guarding LeBron James
so sighs doesn't obviously matter with
with Pat Bev but I love his heart and
his team they feed off of that the key
for Patrick Beverley he's got to stay
healthy because he plays with a reckless
abandon he sacrifices his body so you
hope he can stay healthy throughout the
duration of the regular season Reggie we
had a poll question last week that
caused a lot of problems I don't think
you got a chance to weigh in
we asked who's a better player right now
Kawhi Leonard or LeBron and that was out
there last week Dan said LeBron can you
see Dan's case right now as we speak
right now this year you know not not
three years I have to disagree with that
right now I would say Kawhi Leonard is
the better player this is what
LeBron's 17:17 season he's 34 years old
still great still a top-five player but
he doesn't bring the same defensive
identity that quite he's not as
disruptive defensively as Kauai has been
the last couple years and even at the
start of this season don't get me wrong
he can Ray he could rise to that level
but right now the best two-way player
and the best player between those two in
my opinion if Kawhi Leonard Reggie
Brandon Ingram seems to be coming into
his own this season is that a product
more of where he's playing or just sort
of that maturity of his fourth season
for New Orleans yeah I think it was a
breath of fresh air not a lot of
pressure to play with LeBron the Lakers
because there's a lot of expectations
and not a lot of people can do it I mean
you can almost make the same case like
for the Yankees you know for the Yankees
this championship or bust basically well
for the Lakers and for the Celtics it's
basically championship or bust and when
you're on that stage and you're playing
with the best player of his generation
and LeBron well expectations come with
that and when you were top three pick
like Ingram was and you come out and
don't play up to your capabilities well
you're probably going to hear from your
critic so I think going to New Orleans
was a breath of fresh air from it gives
a chance to relax and I think with the
injury to Zion Williamson this is a
chance for him to kind of establish his
roots there and bring out his game and
we're seeing the athleticism that we saw
while he was at Duke he just needs to
kind of parlay that and extend it and
see if he can you know get a run going
where he has good weeks that run in two
months and hopefully he can be one of
those players that uh coach Gentry can
count on
once Williamson's come back Reggie I was
looking at what Russell Westbrook had to
say after the game I was always
interested in your mindset how you can
go from you know being playful before a
game and you know maybe you're cordial
with guys you know on the other team but
this is what Russell Westbrook had to
say after the game about his mindset and
his reference to who he's friends and
not friends with this all goes and I
hope I have no friends on the court
they're they know not the talking but
Steve is a real close friend of mine
born inside those lines there's no
friends squadron that's my friend and my
teammates and that's it but before the
game after the game I'll talk to my guys
I will talk to right now but doesn't
mean they don't have
during a game I don't that simple if you
try to be my friend I ain't gonna say to
you what you what do you make of that as
far as your mindset and how you can
relate to it westbrook listen amen
that's how it should be you know tired
of all the hugs and the kisses and you
know patting each other on the back that
that's how you're supposed to approach
it he's an anomaly right now right so
that's not how most NBA players are most
of them have partnerships and deals
right and banana boats and and he's
old-school and I love that you know that
kind of how I was taught from magic and
Michael Cooper and Byron Scott you know
and don't ever help anyone else off the
floor and you know your band of brothers
your teammates that's who you can count
on and that's how you kind of go into
Warren to battle you know and I think
Russell has that persona and at times
people think he's a little bit of Lou
but that's just russ being rough i love
the dog in him you know i here to be
your friend i'm not out here to pick you
up i ain't out here to pat you on the
back i'm out here to go through your
your chest and dunk on you and embarrass
you I mean you've got to have it these
are the best players in the world the
most talented players in the world and
if you don't have that mindset that
you're one of the best and you're out
here to be the alpha dog then you're
gonna get eaten up by some of these
great players
Reggie Miller joining us in the Dan
Pacioretty on the call Hawks hosting the
heat 7 p.m. Eastern with Kevin Harlan on
TNT right after that Nuggets at the
pelicans let's go with the Hawks even
though the Hawks are kind of the team
where you're not sure if they're gonna
be good yet it seems like Trey young
their young guard out of Oklahoma is
hitting his stride he's ever done 34
points per game leading the team in
assists
second rebounds this is seems like an
obvious question but he does seem like
the high end byproduct of Steph Curry I
agree and he's one of those players
where you can build around he has ice
water in his veins where there's a lot
of guys that shy away at the end that
you guys know this to shy away at the
end of the games they might have a great
game all the way up to that point
but when it comes to winning time do you
really want to take that shot are you
the one who really wants to make those
big plays Trey young is one of those
players who wants to make the big play
he he doesn't shy away from the moment
or the spot
and I think this is a good hard-working
young Atlanta Hawks team you can build
around young you can build around
Collins Cam reddish DeAndre hunter out
of Duke so they've got some great young
players coach Chris is doing a good job
of letting the reins loose to allow them
to get up and and play in transition a
little bit more and use that youth it
was a tough loss loss last night at home
versus Philadelphia you know they were
in control of that game and that's the
kind of Knox you're gonna take from this
young team they play hard up to a
certain extent but teams that have more
talent and more veteran presence can
beat them solely on that they're gonna
have to learn and find a way to win
these close games if they have a if they
want to have a shot of scratching in at
that a spot in the Eastern Conference
speaking in the Sixers Reggie
three-and-oh the only three a note
Eastern Conference team the guys are
gonna kill me for tell you this it seems
like the process might be complete now
three games is this is the process over
is this the best team in the east along
with Milwaukee but the thing with the
process is how many games is the process
going to play because you know they're
gonna go towards load management it's a
long season if he plays 72 to 75 games I
do think they'll have home court
advantage if he plays less than that I
believe Milwaukee will have the best
record that to me those are the two best
teams in the Eastern Conference and then
probably followed up by Boston and after
that it's a crapshoot in the Eastern
Conference so the most talented teams in
my opinion are out west but two of the
best teams that could win championships
are in the East and that's to Milwaukee
in Philadelphia has been Simmons I we
saw a lot of videos improving a shot is
he ready to hit a three-pointer and be
kind of an MVP candidate I won't believe
it I see it I saw it during the
exhibition season and it was the lead
story on SportsCenter but until I see it
in live action and
in an exhibition preseason game it's
it's the one thing especially come
playoff time during the regular season
he'll be able to skirt around it and get
around it because you play one team and
you move on to the next and there's not
a lot of time to prepare but once you
get locked into a playoff series which
we saw last year and teams start taking
away your a B and C move and you've got
to be able to go into your bag of tricks
and invent something until he gets a
jump shot and I'm not talking about a
three I don't want him shooting threes
really I can benefit no 15 to 18 because
of his length along with Yanis if those
dude got a 15 18 21 foot jump face you
up and knock that down like MJ because
now you got a crowd of and now it's one
dribble and they're putting fouls on
your sinners and getting to the
free-throw line
ripe already that calendar Ben's been
Simmons is old for 17 his career first
two years Oh first 11 over six issues
over Oh in the preseason he had a three
in a place went berserk and it's almost
like a comic relief moment wouldn't be
good to be jacked up a few threes early
nail one and get that off his back and
we don't ever talk about it then and go
back to being that mid-range shooter
that you talked about just jack a few up
losing or winning just put him up early
and get it over with you know he plays a
lot like LeBron where he plays the right
way so he's not gonna come out just to
jack the Ruiz to get one down so people
get off his back I think he's biding his
time until he finds the right three I
know he's worked on history just this
past summer we know that you know the
evidence is all on Instagram and YouTube
and all that of him working on his his
shot it'll come he'll be patient I'm
just saying if he wants to take that
next step and beat that MVP candidate
you just alluded to him being he's gonna
have to be a consistent face-up jump
shooter because he is so talented with
his back to the basket he's great with
both hands around the basket six eight
six nine point guard but he's got to be
able to keep the defense honest with
their jump shot last question about that
Reggie
Ben Simmons is over 17 his career do you
think and I'm being very serious about
this practice game anywhere playground
you ever missed 17 three-pointers in a
row in your entire life from birth to
now yes I'm saying joking around in the
backyard playing in it for the Pacers
playing for it no we actually checked no
we went back to your grade school your
high school you never miss it coming Ben
stay patient
don't jack up threes like Paulie wants
you to be take your time but do work on
your 15 to 18 footer because if he got
that down
Yanis if you euro didn't VP you would be
in the Jordan type stratosphere if Yanis
got a jump shot it's scary if Yanis gets
one reggie by the way i don't know if
you saw the headline Dan Patrick himself
is competing in our three on three
League or considering maybe owning a
team maybe playing like Jordan in the
Wizards the a you a a but as you know
Dan is suffering with kidney stones
might take a while to get his legs back
if Dan Patrick is not ready for the
beginning of the season are you willing
to step in Dan's place in the Danette
three-on-three battle busy he's got a
[ __ ] for jobs well I do Thank You Paulie
I do got it work huge news for the brand
wouldn't upgrade to this league is our
our best player in league history is
Andrew McLovin pearl off to go from that
to Reggie Miller would be a huge jump
for the league I'm with you guys reg
thanks I would come in mess with my boy
thanks a lot for joining us hopes all
going well out there thanks a lot but
that was Reggie Miller and being a great
friend of the show great family member
of the show for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience Channel 239 on
Direct
a stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]